before the break a brief break will be
given by dr. lee Hong Liang of also
function hi University the title of her
talk is the neural correlates of trait
room in rumination actually I just
changed my head off hello everyone is
such a good pleasure to be here I'd like
to thank that mr. and mrs. McGowan and I
really appreciate for their great
contribution to this neuroscience field
and I'd like to thank McGovern Institute
for emerging us what I would like to
talk today is about rumination stress
and depression moaner ability thank you
so as everyone else in this room I am
really really curious about our brain oh
I like to fascinate is about whether we
have intrinsically in our brain have a
network wired and that Network has been
tricked like changed by our experience
and how that is change hours between you
and differentiate between you and me and
how that change when they get to the
mental disorders so my study actually
mainly focus on the neural circuits
related to emotion and cognition but
today I would like to talk a little
about depression vulnerability actually
all the words i put here are my interest
I interesting words I mean keywords that
have me interested I think everybody
here knows about depression and knows
how aunt ever sleep it is to us through
our life and I one thing of like to
mention is in China that's only while
sort of patients go to the clinic
and there's high ratio of suicide every
year but many of them probably have
depression so it's really too important
to detect who are wonderful to
depression earlier as early as possible
but for the vulnerability of depression
I think this is a very nice review paper
by north but dr. not no tips group and
it has risk genes based and also changes
in your own transmitters and also the
brain structures and the important thing
is he here actually sep like group to
three types of phenotypes like if you
have the increased self-focus probably
you you have the changes in the resting
state activity or if you have mail
adaptive emotion activity and that might
be increase your increase your strengths
stress sensitivity or if you have your
reward induced activity reduced then you
may have estonia actually am increasing
aware i will talk listen to that too
loose talk I think maybe someday we can
have this photo tube today to stimulate
our dorsal raphe at natura to change
anyway today I'd like to talk of like
focus on two phenotypes one is increase
the South focus that is increase the
stress sensitivity actually I would like
to talk about this too to emphasize two
things in this in this new imaging field
I think there's we as an ER imager we
are in the very exciting and exciting
and child engineer because there are so
many new methodologies has been
developed in doing data analysis and
particularly for the network brain and
all the old can
subs is changing in this code paradigm
shift but I so like the brain initiative
we want to have large data set to really
to find out what's the weather was the
stable signal from from our brain but I
would like to say from while you're
looking at this large data set what's
important is to looking at the commons
between them so in so today would like
to talk one example is this you're
looking at different states of the brain
and looking at how in that area whether
there are some common findings so then
you can using that kind of information
to do the support machine learning so
that you get a good feature for them
that is what I'm talking one of those is
increase the South focus illumination
South focus which is illumination in
depression rumination actually in my
talking rumination actually we can't
forget this and this scientist dr. Susan
Sudha hoeksema actually she is the para
near and she has built up a lot of work
in looking at domination rimini she is a
mode of responding to this dress and
that he will repeatedly and passively
focusing on symptoms of distress and
possibly and on the possible course and
sequence consequence of the symptoms so
it's really focusing on the negative
side of self and rumination does not
help for problem solving instead of just
focusing a fixed fixated and the
problems without doing an action so that
people who have rumination have the
predicts the depression unset and also
who have the Roman tation has stay
longer
treatment I mean not responding to
treatment that's quick and also have
repeat have recurrence of depression so
doctor doctor no nola hug Simha actually
she developed the Illuminati response
tell this is a questionnaire we use that
to looking at how you're having higher
or lower rumination nominative function
so there's in the literature i think
there's us that is like looking at well
when you in the web inducing people to
in the illuminative status what the
brain activation look like so the task
is we asking you to think about what
people notice about your personality on
the contrary the country as you think
about a role of shampoo bottles of
display since this part of display this
bothers more concrete image so they
develop another app the contrast which
is abstractive sentence so think about
what contributes to team spirit so
they're looking at what rumination
versus control condition and they found
that in in depression that didn't have
those a decreased activation in the subj
annual cingulate our practice actually
on the other hand rumination was this
abstract sentence is actually showed
greater activation in those hippocampus
amygdala mess are in peril pocampus and
pcc area so these are the wooden people
these are the conditions that when
people were induced illumination
activity but typically because this is
in the block design and you may not
always focusing on this condition so
there are some limitations of the task
on the other hand dr. Rideau in from
arsenal's lab they looking at well your
reappraisal on your emotion feeling so
the
case we give you a queue of increase or
decrease or just looking at those
pictures and then after the q show the
neck two pictures are our neutral
pictures and asking you so then you have
to reduce the emotion and by
self-focusing like if you enhance the
emotion yourself focusing on this
picture or you reduce the emotion by we
are we thinking of the solution is
somebody else and nothing important and
then you're asking the how you have your
effect change by look Patti looking at
this they look they found that the
rumination actually is correlated with
the anterior cingulate in the condition
love just looking at the pictures versus
decrease the emotion and so this does
ventral medial prefrontal cortex of Lucy
is related to the emotion regulation so
then this are in the normal healthy
subjects so then they were actively
coping lessness emotion so we would like
looking at just rising status like let's
say on during whether you have if you're
sensitive to depression maybe you have
been wired and have the hype it
highlighted intensive of the
connectivity during the resin state and
I used us there are several methods of
looking at resins days but one of this
is using the seed based connectivity so
what seed base second activities is you
just looking at one region to looking at
up and down off the booze and then
looking at what other areas of the brain
have the similar terms at synchronized
with this area so that's code
functionally connected so we used syrup
those regions that has been proposed
related to emotions self-focus and
memory and executive function related to
depression and to looking at this
depression association
with rumination traits rumination with
the functional connectivity we're
looking at first we're looking at a
young house adults under trips and
depletion so with tryptophan is the
precursor of serotonin and after you
give the 16 like 15 typically have 16
balanced immunizes which is important
for for our immune Isis but when you
reduce one of the tryptophan and then by
competition you have low trip weapon and
through the brain have low serotonin so
this is pretty quick is that the four of
three to five hours using the peak you
have low serotonin your brain and so
we're looking at android so just like
dr. Lewis has just said that serotonin
is related to depression and so this is
one way to looking at certain in effect
and will wonder what wondered that when
you have a temporary loss sir turning
what to bring whether those who have
higher on rumination treat have changed
or not in their functional connectivity
and the other is looking at the older
people and the reason I'm when looking
at older people actually is thinking if
you have this rumination treat but you
don't have depression so that maybe you
have to have some protective entry but
on the other hand who have developed
what sorts those who developed
depression and so this is the experiment
about this okay tryptophan depletion
force we have the control condition we
give people 16 min Isis and after five
hours three hours with two after my
study and verses we give them trip to 15
types of immunizes by liking of
tryptophan and doing the Ephraim eyes
scan so actually here we have those
emotional task and also decision
rewarding tasks we didn't find any
significance regarding the decision in
the rewarding actually but today I was
just certainly looking
at the talking about the resting state
functional connectivity so this just
showed the after three hours the
tryptophan level becomes lower and we
did ever my during the slow period
objective Enochian so this is that we
use the seed seed paste so this just
show one seat and PCC area and this the
yellow yellow colors are the activations
of the connectivities from the PCC area
with the PVC area and witches can by
comparing the lower figures which comes
from Fox at all and it's just saying
this are really mimic the study and we
found that in those deprived the
patients on a bronzer and those who have
higher rumination actually showed
greater change from connectivity from
the pieces due to middle frontal gyros
area so this is a chance to connectivity
change between the tryptophan depletion
versus a control condition so this after
the trip dental patient they have
increased connectivity between PCC and
middle frontal jurors as you know the
PCC is the region of default mode
network and middle frontal dare resist
as positive a network typically this to
network are negatively correlated and
this is to sing under depression chip
acute tryptophan you have he has the
updates way of connectivity between the
two network on the other hand we also
looking at the looking at the
association with anxiety actually it
shows differently so the anxiety
actually associated with the increase
the connectivity between pc series a
Mickle area so i'm not sure this will be
generalized on out but this is just the
differentiating at some point
differentiating depression roses
anxiety so we also looking at
illumination in older adults and thus as
I show you in the next figure actually
those in those older adults it don't
really have much of the high rumination
score so but it's the picture looks like
this it's just as you have greater
connective if you have the higher
rumination score actually you have lower
connectivity between PCC and MFG area
this is just opposite to that to trip
them depletion and other hand in
depression that doesn't have any of
those connectivity just that an
associate with rumination and so this
actually do remove the effect of
depression on the other hand we found
that from the seed of a make the lights
show the greater connectivity with the
sub J no single age in the MFG and
through the from terrace area in page
impatience so this just shows the
difference between you have temporal
temporally reduce the serotonin versus
you have depression so in healthy
subjects you have an active connectivity
between PCC and & MFG area but in
temporary when you temporarily do
serotonin level you have increased
connectivity between certain you have
increased connectivity between PCC and
middle frontal terrors and also in
depression have increased connectivity
between MFG re obese amygdala so this
just show you an example of when you're
looking at those different mental status
that will give you some feature of
whether there's common area related to
associate related to rumination
so another talk Alex I would like to
address here is this increase the stress
sensitivity so as we know that the
support vector machine learning is
helping I mean is everybody right now is
looking at using this message to
differentiate to giving us a class
classification diagnosis hoping that in
some day to have helped us to do that
individualize the diagnosis but one
thing of like mention is so far is
across the the publication's they're
just the classifier they found this only
stays with that data set it doesn't come
across these different data sets so
that's why I mentioned previously so if
we use the common the features that we
demonstrate from different data sets are
different mental status then that will
help us to for the individualized
diagnosis okay give us a better future
for classifier another hand we probably
can using the dynamic change pattern to
looking at for the individualized
diagnosis so this actually I would like
to talk to us in using this example of
increase the stress sensitivity so as
you know that many of the depression
often comes with you have a acute stress
or worse event and you have the passion
but actually it's not everybody have
depression after acute stress actually
have this genetic risk are in early laps
dress and then you have those community
nature and also the negative bias versus
somebody who are resilient for
depression that maybe have positive bias
or mindfulness in my hypothesis is that
if you have repeatedly let receive a
stressor for those who are resilient to
depression to stress maybe they showed
us the activation lactose in their
emotional regions
so they get increased activation the but
gradually habituated to it as I call the
debilitating emotional response on the
other hand if you for those who are one
about oppression they may incredibly
increase their activation in their
emotional region and state state plateau
or a sensitized to it so that's we
called prolonged emotional response so
looking at whether we give subjects this
repair repeatedly giving that the stress
whether we can find this pattern in the
brain so one thing of like to mention is
this early laps dress actually that
which is a is a wonder is a 1-1 durable
factor for depression and so dr. Taylor
actually did a lot of work in
documenting this early life stress and
later life mental disorders and she also
found that in those who have who have
family risk factor who have been raised
by risky families and then how they had
actually reduced activation in the
middle area which is quite opposite to
what we thought but actually it's just
because of the long term the stress they
have really inhibit activation in a big
below so what we'll use this looking at
those repetitive subjects repeated
stress task subjects doing mental maths
stressful tacitus has been validated by
many other labs that sister in distress
we're looking at this repeatedly doing
stress versus reputed doing mantha task
and we're because we're looking at the
change across time we our or interest
looking at the first run response to
what is the last run but if the first
run has greater activation than the last
one we think this is the habituation
fact or maybe it's because is the
cognitive change on the other hand if
subjects show the pattern actors over
the say this probably is
vulnerable I have to say that this has
to be in the emotional rage not in the
cognitive control region and so this is
of the self on the lab side is the
self-rating stress and it's obviously
during the stress man mental math task
you have shown increased have greater
stress was reading than the immense task
and also subjects showed relatively
increase a heartbeat then the man
fulness task but not not breathing in
interestingly for this this isn't
younger normal subjects so then in
general overall we found that in many
areas in emotional related to motion
like in amygdala and hippocampus of user
from terrorists or all sold habituated
response and we didn't find the opposite
side in other group wise but increase
namely looking at the correlation with
the early life stress course it shows
that and those who have early laps to as
higher or lab scores and actually showed
increased activity in the fur not
increase or decrease activity from the
first to the last run and particularly
that you saw so she with the emotional
views so Alvin I have mentioned that we
use this man Finister but I didn't
mention this the measure that we use
actually we also looking at the
treatment Venus which using this five
passage a month questionnaire is about
observe and describe act with awareness
non-judgment of hindered explore
experience and now reactivity of inner
experience so these are defined how your
month or not and if this mansion is
actually one of them we're looking at
the correlation
chain of those five passage with the
illumination as with rumination and the
thought we found that only this non
reactivity showed correlation absences
part negative correlation with
rumination trees and we are also looking
at we differentiate our subjects by
looking at who are wonderful depression
by if subjects have early depressed
early life stress or not and if they
have and whether they have illumination
tendency and also have low madness so if
so we define them as depression
vulnerable on the other hand if subjects
have already loves dress but have high
maintenance on low rumination we think
probably they have depression resilience
so we're looking at the pattern of those
two group and we found that in the
depression vulnerable subjects in the
middle area they actually showed pattern
that what we predicted so they showed
gradually increased activation in the
middle Abbott as they plateau and on the
other hand in the ventromedial
prefrontal cortex which is related to
emotional regulation and negative
correlated with amygdala actually shows
from the first to show the later two
runs the show decrease activation on the
other hand for those we define as a
depression resilient showed up deciding
the amygdala social gradually decrease
activation across runs but in on the
other hand in the ventral medial probe
approaches is just keep having the high
activation across all runs and for those
who doesn't have early life stress and
so they showed not typical of what we
can characterize this but interestingly
if you can see that for the depression
in the in the middle area in the
vulnerable depressed you know depression
one both subjects actually they don't
have a greater activation than than
those who are resilient to the press in
general overall but is just a fit for
this pattern so but by showing this I
would like to say this if you're looking
at the pattern of across time
that might give you something about
individualized diagnosis so yeah we're
also looking at how the inactive non
reactivity protected resource from
stress and we found that this is a no go
no go task and in this the red and green
or activation to inactive go and an
active no go as because they are
overlapping sumerian in the insular and
inter frontal cortex area and thus
showing that this area actually is
response to negative per se and we found
that in those who have non reactivity of
man fulness actually showed up like
showed up such negative connected
negative activation in the insular area
so which suggesting that there doesn't
respond much to negative with response
which probably is a protective feature
was to further explore so the summarized
I would like to say that if we're
looking at common findings across
different mental status that will give
us a good feature of the disease and if
you're looking at the namek changes
pattern in for my signals which we can
allow us to have individualized
diagnosis those are actually all the
work has a mission actually system that
Duke and I just moved to China and we
are continues doing the same study but
we want looking at who r is the genetic
and also there's rumination characters
thank you oh so this is the picture of
quinoa in this spring so welcome
so um so I'd like to ask you what you
consider early life stress and whether
or not an individual resolves that
stress could make a big difference in
terms of how it affects them earlier so
some people who have a very stressful
young life and overcome it can't be
swayed at all right and and then I'm not
sure what you mean by mindfulness so do
you take account of first of all
different kinds of stresses and what are
the determinants of mindfulness so
actually this madness I just starting
from them that the madness is what we
just based on that 55 cm the measure
actually is when you're observing so
what we have the last we think is
important to us not having protect us
from depression is is this when some
stressful events have coming you don't
response immediately it's no reactivity
that's how you define but so right now
there's a lot of manful base the train
treatment you so therapy so those
teaching people to actually is focusing
on your I think the the ideal situation
is your mind is out of your body is mind
not associations write down a ladder of
yourself so that is the condition of
training and this has several lots of
studies showing that you can after the
therapy you can increase your attention
and cognition even so for the early life
stress actually it's increasing like
there's also several features like
physical abuse or emotion abuse and the
emotional Act and many of those is also
we have those just questionnaire to fill
out in there bunch of literature's that
show that it can last to affect your
later life but as I showed here some of
those who
half early life and I can get a real fit
and get half this madness I think that
my related to some other later life
experience and also self you know
cognitively adapt adoption i think so
that's a very important maybe i can
follow what muscle juice asked about
mindfulness and illumination so on your
table you define people with early life
stress either as vulnerable versus
resilient and in that um you use
lumination and mindfulness as to add
things up observed measures do they
always go hand in hand in other words if
you have scores low in mindfulness is
always show illumination and vice versa
because someone could be you know having
illumination and yet arm having a lower
having a higher mindfulness right
meaning scoring to himself it doesn't
have to be going hand in hand what if
you have a situation where someone has
nomination and yet our high mindfulness
well that's a good question i think we
what our data shows this is show the
negative correlation but yeah i don't i
don't think i can absolutely like
exclude that make the two it's quite
absurd but theoretically yes so the you
have you can if you have good observant
and not responding and probably you
should have lower ruminative feature but
that may not a hundred percent not
happening though it's worth looking at
lean larger sample so we just have a
very good example there is no simple yes
i think actually my question may be
related somewhat to yours i noticed the
two large personality factors you had up
there or negative activity and positive
affective
if you look at the arc if the telogen
multi-dimensional personality
questionnaire which has been linked to
genetic studies of twins that also
includes conscientiousness and then each
one of those factors is related to sub
factors and I find myself thinking both
as a clinician is a researcher that
rumination in fact would be good for
some people but it might be not so good
for other people so with co vary as a
function of personality traits so that's
the first thing we know there are
biological underpinnings to that the
other thing is that um there are studies
out there that show that depression in
fact improves reality testing for some
folks so I wonder if what we're talking
about is a relationship between stressed
out people who have negative experiences
that are encoded in the amygdala and a
particular epistemology I mean that's
cognitive behavior therapy which is only
one way of thinking about therapy and
thinking about personality so I guess
I'm I'm wondering would it make sense to
look at personality traits and how they
covary and also to begin to think about
the advantages of depression and by this
I don't mean a hypomanic approach to
stuff right so you're right that
ruminations one aspect of it and is also
weekend looking at negative bias and
other like Narada neuroticism actually
we did included the the the five Big
Five personality but I didn't do it
because I don't want to do mouth porque
no reason I just didn't do that analysis
yet I think it's worth looking at
that's er that's right that's right yeah
that's right yeah source to look yet all
right thank you